we'll understand two important concepts
in this video
consider two intersecting lines a and b
how many angles are formed when two
lines intersect
you can see that four angles are formed
angle one angle two angle three and
angle four
look at angles one and three
they are opposite each other and are
always equal
they are called vertically opposite
angles
angles 2 and 4 are also opposite each
other and are also equal
this pair of angles as well are called
vertically opposite angles
well it looks as if angles 1 and 3 are
vertical while angles 2 and 4 are
horizontal
but in any case such pairs of angles are
always called vertically opposite angles
this was the first concept
most of you would be familiar with the
second concept though
if we have a line on a plane and a ray
from any point on the line
then two angles are formed angle one and
angle 2.
the sum of these two angles will always
equal 180 degrees
angles 1 and 2 form a linear pair
they are called linear because together
they form a line
these two concepts will help us
understand an important concept which we
will see in the next video